I  Claire Simone  just buy heroin some stable pal a dart  dart the whole day she sticking with it  hello do not let that happen if Maddox  hits you everything but your life  support will shut down some more pain  you've ever felt in your life but a  number there than few a lot  that's not true for instance one time I  wanted to have a bunch of my friends  over to watch TV not unlike this TV that  just showed up magically and not  everybody can fit on my one couch and I  thought to myself well what if there was  such a thing as a bunk bed but as a  couch introducing the double-decker  couch so everyone could watch TV  together and be buddies there's  literally the dumbest thing I've ever  heard please file style let me handle  this that idea is just the worst